with a timely theme about a world
overrun by Ai and a daring Visionary
director at the helm Hollywood had high
hopes for Gareth Edwards nearest film
The Creator so why did it bomb 2023 has
been a pretty weird year when it comes
to box office Gams superhero movies like
Blue Beetle and the Flash are facing
diminishing returns as audiences seem to
Tire of the genre meanwhile Barbie and
Oppenheimer which created the phenomenon
dubbed barbin Heimer saw absolutely
absurd bug office numbers Barbie handily
crossed a billion doll Mark within a few
weeks at oppenheim performed quite well
for a 3-hour historical epic about the
father of the atomic bomb with so many
projects focusing on real life stories
or existing intellectual property it
feels rare to see daring original works
unfortunately writer director Gareth
Edwards latest attempt at this the
Creator flopped at the box office the
film made just over $30 million
worldwide during its opening weekend on
an $80 million budget so what happened
here the film tells a story of a
futuristic world where humans find
themselves at War with artificial
intelligence a bold concept indeed
Gareth Edwards also assembled an
extremely capable cast without any major
movie stars among them the film was led
by John David Washington and also
includes Allison Janney and Ken wanabi
unfortunately for the Creator it seems
none of these actors proved to be a huge
draw Additionally the creator also ran
into the problem of the SAG after strike
which has been going strong since July
after The Writers Guild of America
started striking against the alliance of
motion picture and television producers
in May actors joined them on the picket
lines their primary concerns were
streaming residuals and the Advent of AI
technology in entertainment the issue is
that none of the movie stars could
promote the Creator without crossing the
picket lines as discussing past present
or future work is prohibited for sag
after members joing the strike John
David Washington and his co-stars stood
firm alongside fellow actors for fair
pay and a solid deal from the studios
all we want is a fair deal plus join the
leadup to the release of the Creator
late night shows were still off the air
while the w GA finalized their deal with
the amtp so the regular outlets for
actors to promote their work were also
shut down the Creator didn't bomp
specifically due to the strike but it
certainly didn't help things as writers
and actors in the entertainment industry
tried to ensure that Studios won't find
ways to completely replace them with AI
technology the Creator comes along
spreading a message that not all AI is
bad for most of the movie audiences are
led to believe that the AI is evil and
the humans are good ultimately it's
revealed that the robots just want to
exist in peace and leave humans alone
the massive destruction they cause at
the beginning of the narrative is an
unintended mistake what do you want
sweetie for robots to be free people are
learning more and more about AI right
now especially thanks to the strike and
that probably didn't help the Creator
very much either in a time when actors
and writers are indicating Studios would
happily replace real humans with digital
likenesses asking audiences to
sympathize with a cute robot child might
be a bit of a stretch certainly nobody's
saying Gareth Edwards is arguing we
should have more AI in the ENT
detainment industry but the timing
definitely isn't ideal a final reason
for why the film may have bombed is a
misleading marketing campaign the
Creator is about a man named Joshua
Taylor who after losing his wife Maya
protects a childlike robot named Alfie
and keeps us safe from the United States
government you're my friend does the
marketing for the movie indicate
anything about that relatively simple
plot no not really it's perfectly
reasonable that Gareth Edwards wanted to
keep some of the film's bigger twists
and surprises and the wraps but the
point here is that between a complex
trailer and posters that focus more on
the robotic characters than the human
ones potential viewers could have been a
little confused as to what the Creator
even is despite earning decent reviews
from critics the fact remains that a
myriad of factors led to the Creator
flopping at the box
office